good morning John first I don't have
time to analyze the whole census right
now I really wish I did but I'm going to
right now I don't have time because
there's a lot to do today but I will say
that until you're unnecessarily negative
campaign started my hair was winning
handily and now surprise surprise it's
losing obviously this isn't a thing that
matters it's not a big deal but I will
say that if my hair ends up losing it is
an indictment of the entire process of
democracy if you look at the daily
trends and yes you could look at daily
trends I love this survey I'm so excited
to analyze it my hair was kicking your
hair's butt every day until you made
your video second book towers oh my god
we got so many amazing astounding book
towers like there was almost 900 book
tower sent to Hank and Jonna gmail.com
and they are all beautiful some of them
make me uncomfortable with how amazing
they are to all the people who are able
to make book towers thank you for
putting your time and effort into it I'm
very sad that there can only be ten
winners but that's the rule I made up so
where would we be without rules I will
say though that many of the winners
appeared to be violating one of the
rules we just don't do anything that
might be dangerous and I can't imagine
you built these towers without standing
on one of the steps of the ladder that
says this is not a snap but I don't have
any way of knowing that for sure so I'm
giving you the benefit of the doubt that
you didn't do anything dangerous fingers
crossed
who texted me without further ado though
here are the winners for the tallest
towers we have of Abbey at number one
with a 483 centimeter tall tower
she says that no part of the tower is
touching a wall and I'm trusting her
this one from Abbey Emma drew sue and
Rob this one from Scott this one from
Pete this one from Josh and we're going
to add in Steve just because Josh and
Steve's were really close together using
most stylin was ridiculously difficult
because of course it's subjective and
there were a lot of amazing submissions
but here's what we're going with
we've got Heather and Michelle's
nerdfighter sign and dftba Lauren's
Christmas tree of books the arched tower
of twists from Morton the rocket from
Alexa of Lara and Abby and Katie's
amazing recreation of ministereth which
remarkably was not the only recreation
of minas tirith that was
mitten I had to have two honorable
mentions the one for engineering which
goes to Brian because this book tower
doesn't look like it should work that's
just really remarkable had I have a
three legged book tower this tall and
the other goes to the nerd craft area
minecraft server which had over 30
people working four days to build this
really remarkable minecraft book tower
that I have very much enjoyed exploring
it's full of surprises if you want to go
check it out you can go to em seed craft
area calm their dink nerdcon stories is
coming up and I recently was talking
about it and I said Cassandra Clare I
was gonna be there she's not I was wrong
I apologize but there are gonna be many
other amazing people they've got Holly
black mara Wilson MT Anderson in the
look of the night Vale folks novel
Hopkinson Jacqueline Woodson Rainbow
Rowell John Scalzi Stephanie Perkins Pat
Rothfuss and me and John and Martin
Martin Martin abhi great fourth let's go
get on an airplane okay bye you never on
vlogbrothers anymore
how about that Johnson have chat all the
time
you included
hi John I'll see you on now